vladimir gutierrez the rookie and the
way this season has unfolded with
castillo getting off to a slow start
sunny gray has dealt with injuries i'm
not sure the reds will be where they are
without this rookie vladimir gutierrez
swing and a miss
chase the high heat
swing and a miss got him to chase back
to back punch outs for gutierrez
lakewood though looks like to start with
the bang he's got two of those lead off
home runs this season and the counts two
and two he's had himself a series six
for eleven a home run triple three
doubles
five runs scored and puts a charge into
one right center field kiss that baby
goodbye
well starting with the bang indeed
one nothing
cincinnati
looks like that's a change-up right
there
and naquin
who has done such a great job of hitting
the ball the other way weights on it
gets the bat head to it in those hands
lightning for the marlins they hand it
off to sandy alcatra 26th start of the
season for him coming off a tough luck
loss against the braves
and he gets the call on the outside
corner
the 1-2
right back to gutierrez
i think that's a great point we heard
pablo say it last week we heard don
mattingly just say it how important it
is for him to be
logging innings at the major league
level
two balls two strikes from sandy and he
gets him to chase back-to-back
strikeouts for alcantara bounce back has
been fantastic for sandy
very fantastic in this third inning he
strikes out all three many faces
and the answer is if you're winning no
[Applause]
swinging and a miss
first time through the order
nine up
nine down for vladimir gutierrez in
scoring position that's the tying run
azusa fly out to center his first time
up two balls and a strike
and that is a fair ball jazz is coming
around third he's going to score
and jesus sanchez has tied things up
with an rbi double here with two outs in
the fourth well the overshift was on
now generally when a pitcher comes
inside to get your attention and make
you move your feet he's trying to set up
something away
now that's exactly what happened sanchez
a little bit of a q shot down that third
baseline but in today's game
that's an rbi double mustache is nowhere
near the third base bag
that took uh well from that angle a
left-hand turn to stay fair now the
go-ahead run in scoring position
in the air who wants it three defenders
converging it's jose barrero
how do you do
makes it looks so easy
2-2 pitch
and a swing and a miss now again there's
been a little bit more of the strikeout
for joey votto this year
kyle farmer lined it to first and
aguilar right on the bag will double up
castianos
[Music]
strikeout for gutierrez is fifth on his
one and two on mike mustakas and between
mustaches and suarez it has just been
a tough road to hoe at third base
and how about that
take that
i don't want to hear about no stinking
stats
lustakis
takes the turn
and the reds reclaim the lead at 2-1
i'm sure that felt really good
for moose
and you can see geno on the top step
congratulate moose
just about the one area at this
particular time
where you cannot pitch
and sandy comes right back with the
strikeout of barrero he set him down
twice in that 6k
turned in a
one two three frame in the fifth and
there's strikeout number six
squares default gets it down caught in
the air by gutierrez double play
on the right side of the infield
and a called strike three
low inside quarters in 2019 split
between detroit and
chicago but sandy gets the strikeout
back-to-back case in this sixth inning
according to ted williams and an art
that's for sure that is a swing and a
miss sandy leone will throw to first to
complete the strikeout six innings of
one run baseball
now tip into the mid of stevenson down
goes aguilar
seven of them for gutierrez
well you mentioned the ability of
gutierrez to throw that breaking ball a
little bit slower and that's exactly
what he did right there crowd
recognizing the situation
two on two outs two strikes
the one-two
twin got a miss
he struck him out
gutierrez strands two
seven innings of one run baseball for
the rookie and a standing ovation to
boot
damage control
now listen you can't ask him to be
perfect and i think that's kind of where
this ends up going it's like all right
you say to that is it a mistake yeah
sometimes mistakes are going to happen
you're not going to throw 100 perfect
pitches in a start
called strike three dials up 101.
you got a little room off that outside
part of the plate but mustache is down
on strikes
and that is number 10 for sandy alcatra
career high in pitches is
112. back in 2019
number 111 today results in a career
best 11th strikeout for sandy alcatra
and now tyler naquin
delivered one of two solo home runs
today he and mustaches are the offense
for the reds
another drive
tyler naquin how about a two home run
day
some much needed
insurance two-run lead
anthony bass tried to sneak a fastball
by naquin
that's not happening
those hands are explosive
good
it's a second multi-home run game here
in 2021 and both
ironically enough have come from the
lead off spot
now the tying run in the form of louis
brinson at the plate
the 0-1 there goes the runner it's a
ground ball mustache
across devano
get out the brooms
it's a four-game sweep
the reds sweep the
12 marlins over 500.
the 12 games over the 500 mark a new
season high and for now
barring the outcome in san diego
fred's holding on to that second wild
card spot